welcome to this video let's see we on
against a queen's gambit okay a Slav
yeah many possible lines I can like a
play III rarely do that on video let's
see us you're going to play b5 and no
yeah you can play Bishop f5 even here a
sec Sam looks a bit like a lot of a
temple but it's a it's not a big deal
okay let's see if I can provoke rook a 7
what why why can I not take okay so
let's let's check how should I best them
continue him maybe if maybe c5 it's got
a hard time to protect those pawns
anyway and c5 make sure the Queen side
is closed thread three balls Bishop a
six and Quincy six
yeah the meat grinder from Bulgaria
yeah I don't tell me you let the clock
run down four minutes no but looked
quite suspicious if in that regard okay
I'm just going to continue to develop c5
make sure that there's no Knight b6
queen bee six any of that so I think
this was a good move to um yeah to make
sure that he does not have any big down
to play I couldn't take on a six I think
it's a bit too bit too much okay just
castles right yeah he can try to exactly
exactly that to try to prepare you five
but I always at the moment I'm on I'm on
on the d5 pawn as well also with the
Queen so how to continue if i take here
maybe the easiest takes 90 to the sea
for hanging
maybe you can play you five
yeah 22 crota george w bush maybe i
misunderstood him i miss unless
estimated business position okay um but
take on f6 Kim hmm it still looks quite
good but how exactly do I play maybe
take a drug deal one I can just take
deform so probably not bad after Queen
d4 though I cannot really develop the
bishop which is quite annoying maybe
Queen d6 yeah i'm a bit behind a
development this wasn't wasn't the best
possible way to play that's quite clear
i allowed too much him still it's two
pawns and the bishop and so it should be
sufficient to win ya understand that he
does not want to exchange queens but how
do you avoid it now this is under even
worse circumstances as my bishop gets
developed cannot lose the Queen anywhere
else i'm attacking also a five behind to
exchange now and then it's it's really
easy with this super-important tempo of
the bishop on airfreight even controls
v8 so that rugby aid is no move
you know if he takes I have to ship t6
so I take that under control d5 I mean
maybe 90 form mmm yeah should have
thought about that okay I would have
liked to keep the sea pawn but ok it's
still quite nice the way it it is at the
moment with this two connected passers
yeah the bishops simply am control the
whole board next term next up is Bishop
b5 probably and then a form ok lots of
other position for the Bishop Bishop d3
is also not bad at all ok then you can
take and take on a 2m week that grind ok
then I'm just doing it back all the way
it doesn't really matter
it should go all the way to a seven
maybe I should have no no no problem if
i take he threatens you threatened
snotty too so need to move the bush at
one for once and then a seven next Kimmy
how to how to do that now
if it takes I have rugby one this is
winning anyway so the easiest is
probably here oopsie one idea look-see
to Roxy one whoopsie eight this should
be it should be hard to hard to parry I
should at some point make sure they are
not back ranked mated rube c8 just the
idea it is not really doing anything
against it I mean it didn't have much
king d 7 but it's not really saving him
in the long run black resigned yeah bit
of a strange game he just gave away the
b7 pond which is pretty important it's
not just a pawn but it's also the whole
structure but I played it a bit a bit
too relaxed him at this in this
particular stage you know computers
thinks I'm completely winning her this
is probably true but hmm then 94 maybe
yeah oh yeah no maybe I'm too critical
the compass on plus foremost and it's
not going down so calmly I didn't I
didn't play it so terribly bad badly I
mean you know the computer likes my play
actually yeah i thought i would i would
have allowed too much too much really at
at this stage but it seems queenly 60
keeps everything under control I was a
bit more concerned about something like
that but I just keep the pawn there's no
way for him to him to save himself
alright thanks for watching